NARRATOR: In 1982, 40 women
became
the first female firefighters
in New York City history.
But it didn't happen without
a fight led by one woman.
When I was growing
up in the 1950s,
I did not think it was
possible for girls and women
to become firefighters.
Little girls were not expected
to grow up to be anything
other than wives and mommies.
You could be a teacher.
You could be a nurse.
You could be a secretary.
That didn't appeal to me at all.
I want to do things
that little boys
could do when they grew up.
But, you know, best-laid plans.
NARRATOR: After studying history
in college and graduate school,
Berkman attended
law school at NYU.
While I was in law school,
a couple of things happened.
One was I learned that
it's really hard to use
the law for social justice.
Then also I really started to
question the idea that I was
going to be in an
occupation where I
sat behind a desk all day long.
Then I met some New
York City fire officers,
and that's when I discovered how
great the job of firefighting
was.
So I thought, I think
I'll give it a shot.
I also didn't realize that the
New York City Fire Department
had never accepted
an application
from a woman for the entry
exam for firefighting.
That changed in 1977.
For the first time, women
were allowed to apply,
and I applied.
You had to pass two tests.
One was a written test,
which was multiple choice,
and you had to pass a physical
abilities test, which consisted
of a whole number of events.
NARRATOR: Events like climbing
over an eight-foot wall
and carrying a 120-pound
duffel bag over a shoulder
up three flights of stairs
and back down again.
The physical portion
of the firefighter exam
wasn't just unfair.
It was illegal because it
didn't test for the abilities
actually needed to
be trained to perform
the job of firefighting.
And so I went I talked to
Laura Sager at NYU Law School,
and I explained
what had happened.
I said, I don't think
this test is job related.
NARRATOR: So Berkman, Laura
Sager, and Congresswoman Bella
Abzug went to the
head of personnel
at the New York City
Fire Department.
And we say to them, just
develop a job-related test.
And basically the
head of personnel
said to us he wasn't
going to change the test,
and if I didn't like it,
he'd see me in court.
So I sued.
NARRATOR: The lawsuit went on
for years until finally in 1982
Brenda, along with
40 other women,
were allowed into
the training academy.
But because of the animosity
towards the women, instructors
who had a personal
vendetta against women
being firefighters were
allowed pretty much
free reign to do whatever they
want to try and make the women
quit.
They gave us carbon
monoxide poisoning
and, you know, tools
were dropped on us.
They had not prepared
us with gear that fit.
So women with smaller
feet were having
their boots fall off
as they were attempting
to climb the aerial ladder.
We didn't have gloves that fit.
That meant that it was
really hard to hold on
to tools and hose lines
and other kinds of things
that we needed to do.
And was amazing to me was that
very few of that original group
of women quit.
They just hung in there.
And they were being harassed
not only by the instructors
but by their fellow
trainees, the guys.
NARRATOR: The women who
graduated from the fire academy
were assigned to firehouses.
New York finally had its first
group of women firefighters.
But despite overcoming
great challenges,
women still faced adversity
and discrimination
in the firehouse.
There was a lot of overt
hostility and even dangerous
threatening actions
to women firefighters.
Draining of the air tanks--
so when you went into the fire
you'd turn on your air tank,
and all of a sudden
you'd discover
that there was no air in it.
Women were threatened with
being pushed off a roof.
They were sexually assaulted.
They were beat up
at a company picnic.
We did speak out.
We learned that, you know,
the judge can't be with us
in the firehouse
for 24 hours a day,
that the problems of integrating
women into the department
are not going to
disappear overnight,
but things have
definitely gotten better.
I think it's so important
that younger women know
this history, that they
realize that the opportunities
that they have today
didn't just sort
of, like, get handed to them.
We only came through
all those bad times
because good people
refused to be silent,
and they took action.
We can do this, but
we have to work.
We can't leave it to
other people to do.
We have to stand up
and do it ourselves.